hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
oh I'm John Humphrey today we're gonna
watch a trailer for the film that is
presented by Peter Jackson which I'm
sure everyone is now assuming that he
directed it because it's presented by
him hmm it's this movie called mortal
engines it's based on a series of novels
Mortal Instruments city of Gold's no
mortal engine city of cities that I
think it's about cities that are all
contained in cars now on automobile
transport and they move around
oh so before going into this video
though wanted to give a special thank
you to the real rejects video sponsor
that is the Stardust app on Stardust
it's an app that allows you to do
30-second reactions for any film TV show
or trailer recently passed 22 hundred
followers so thank you guys for
following us we love using the app
because there's movies that we're
catching up on or movies that we've
never done reviews on that we get to
give quick opinions about also your
favorite youtubers are using it as well
a lot of them are so it's becoming it's
really popular app we're glad that these
guys are sponsoring us thank you Jake
over at Stardust make sure down the app
follow us first at the real rejects
people link in the description box would
greatly appreciate it and today's
patient the day shout-out andrew
Terpening Terp smith my trailer for
trailer
title car looks cheesy as hell makes it
look like a movie for youth looks like a
90s video okay tree of life
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
that's cool that's really the national
anthem
[Music]
it's some of the same computer Jackson
co-wrote it's wingnut films wingnut I
think it's so the writers who wrote Lord
of the Rings as well and this is from
the director who did all the visual
effects for the Lord of the Rings The
Hobbit
King Kong which is exciting and it's
cool that Peter Jackson's showing his
support and you know me like I'll help
you create this since it's your first
time directing which can be different
than just doing the visual effects
yourself you could have to get a Tim
Miller situation with Deadpool or you
can get the alien beep predator Requiem
yeah a sky yes yes because they're a
great visual effects does I mean it's
gonna be the same without a good helping
producing handy guide you in terms of
directing so Peter Jackson guiding is
cool I know you know how to shoot the
cgc yeah I mean I mean yeah the effects
look really great the effects look
awesome that was great design seeing
London on wheels because the concept is
so bizarre it's such a weird
trippy concept cities desolate like this
Mad Max world but madness water bars
instead of cars it's all the scenes are
for hours yeah the probably cars within
the cars city absorbing a smaller city
and I can only imagine whatever
metaphors are gonna be yeah you know
because this does come from a book yeah
yeah cuz I'm thinking to myself that if
it's coming from a book there's probably
a lot of metaphors there's a lot of
themes there's a lot of messages that
all take place with it cuz it's a book
the issues that I tend to find with
books these days many words only
pictures and they all move really fast
yeah like thought bubbles in there
there's got your work we can move this
along we don't need like ten pages where
the descriptions is my issue that tends
to be with movies adapted from books
especially with source material like
this is that oftentimes you sacrifice
meaning for spectacle yes you get a
visual effects director in there
I'm kind of concerned it'll do that
however with the team behind it you know
like this guy's worked up Jackson who
really does care about story plus
spectacle despite what you think about
The Hobbit films I don't like them but I
know he tried no matter what Peter
Jackson still cares a lot about story
the riders involved are very good
screenwriters a world that all of it
looked scary like this could have easily
just been a trailer were I'm looking at
it going oh that looks cool that looks
exciting I felt a feeling I wasn't
expecting to feel which was whoa this is
kind of terrifying actually
yeah it's very sinister I mean the the
it's so again it's so surreal the idea
of cities Empire on giant wheels is so
weird
you know they probably chopped it up but
it seems like this is mostly one
sequence and that gripped me because
that's how you should do a teaser
trailer yeah and it hooked me it made me
really want to find out what this world
is about you know who the characters are
gonna be I like a teaser like this it
looks distinct it does look distinct and
especially in a world where we're mining
all these books and all these yeah sure
dystopia scenarios I'm like this could
end up being trite but it doesn't look
like any no I see no it doesn't look
like the fate of the hands and a bunch
of youth or it doesn't look like another
Lord of the Rings or Harry Potter
wannabe it looks like its own thing if
any sees the world now yeah the other
thing the closest thing I got to it is
the new Maze Runner movie which no one's
seen yet that's the closest thing I can
think of where it's kind of similar in
imagery but just because it has the
desolate Mad Max Book of Eli vibe about
it and he's got that uh December slot
again Peter Jackson with his December
slots a big deal her brothers always
gives the jacks the December slot yeah
yeah yeah and I hope this I hope this
movie goes forward cuz just reading the
little synopsis I feel like this could
be pretty interesting guys before this
video wraps up shout out today for
Andrew turning have you read this book
have you ready like specifically serve
and returning because this guy reads
ours devours books like nothing this guy
can sing gets women like nobody's
business and then when he has a girl
he's in love with he is committed and
loyal he is like an older brother and a
father at the same time in all aspects
he is six foot nine
can read books like nobody's business
not sure I already mention that I think
that was the first thing I mentioned
probably the main thing that started
this whole thing he also was great
archery he served in the military
he knows he's really good with guns dude
you would you would be good in this
world Terps should have his own I feel
like you're sharpening could uh if we
got into the situation he could be our
leader Eddie oh yes he could be my lead
I just want Andrew to lead me in all
areas I want you to come to the bedroom
II the next time I'm with my girl and I
want you to teach me something you just
lead by example by can you feeling for
me show me what you do then I'll switch
out yeah I would like you to do that for
me but for every other aspect might be
an emotionally confusing heart-wrenching
situation for me but I want to see your
more those where you think of the book
Andrew I'm sure you write all for them
subscribe you the real rejects click
that notification bell make sure to
download the Stardust app and follow us
first police because we want to get to
3,000 followers on that as soon as
possible and also become a patron
ejected a it's like our second YouTube
channel have extra posts over their
exclusive reactions a bunch of extra
vids check it out